[拍手]
皆様はじめまして
行動は言葉よりも雄弁に語るこれは私が好きな言葉のうちの一つです
ちょうど今日から1年前私はてりとるという会社を立ち上げました
起業してから今日まで
思考を形にすることの目指したそして
水川行動し続けることの大切さはこれを日々実感しています
[音楽]
この動画がなの動画かと言いますと私はこれまで毎週違う人と違う場所で
ルームシェア生活をして暮らしていました
なぜか
それは出会う人と身を置く環境を支え続けることが
人生の可能性を広げることにつながるそういった思いから1週間限定で自分と同じ趣味
を持った人たちとルームシェア体験ができる
ウィッグすというサービスを立ち上げていたからです
ですが
今日初めて公の場で言うんですけれどもこの weeks の授業後で理由を説明し
ますがサービスを訪れることを
つい1週間前に決定いたしました
うん
サービス訪れることを決めてから今日私ここに立って何をしゃべろうか
うーん
そもそもここに立っていいものなのか
すごい悩みました
であの悩んだとき私がいつも頼りにしているのが
一緒に会社を立ち上げた共同創業の前は京都文を受けに来てると思うんですけれども
前田に聞いてみたんですね
どうしよう
x 何をとっ
そしたら彼はを言ってくれました
いつも話してるリネン語ればいいじゃんと
俺は別にビジネスモデルに惹かれて一緒に仕事をしているわけではなくて
日沖が抱える
掲げる理念とかしそうそれに共感しているからやっていると
理念を実現しようと行動し続けるその姿勢に惹かれているわけだからそれをより多くの
人に伝えるって言うことはすごい口があることなんじゃないか
そう言ってもらえたので今日ここに立っています
[拍手]
これ youtube で見るよりも皆さん温かいですねハッでしょうか
えーちょっと私の話に戻ります
私は昨年の5月までアメリカのニューヨークで働いておりました
200の新聞社で8働いてたんですけれども
新卒で渡米することを決めました
大学4年生の時に当時お付き合いしていた方に
方がイギリスに行っちゃったんですよ
イギリスに留学に行ったんですね
あいちゃん1さん一緒にイギリスで暮らそうよそう言ってくれたんです
普通がっからもしかしたら女性として喜ばしいことなのかもしれないけれども
私は一緒にイギリスネスもそう言われた時に嫌だなって思ったんです
これまでなんとなく高校に入ってなんとなく大学生活やってなんとなく就職活動をして
そして就職活動もなんとなく彼に追われた一言で諦めてイギリスに行っちゃう
それって誰のための人生か分からなくないそう思ったんです
当時の頭でイギリスの反対ってアメリカだよな
ユーザーって
勝手な思いがあったので私はアメリカのニューヨークで働くことを決めました
ん
実際にニューヨークに行ってからというものも新聞社での営業だったので毎日新聞
100冊抱えてもう八反中を飛び回っていたんですね
でその中で
同年代のアジア人の子たちにすごいたくさん出会いました
中国マレーシアフィリピン後インドも多かったかな
彼らの多くがすでにビジネスを始めている
そしてグローバルでニューヨークで一旗あげてやるお
そんな高い志を持った若い子で溢れていました
都市から3カラー
すごいキラキラして見えた彼らに愛がうらやましそう言われることがあったんです
なんでと聞いてみると
愛は日本人でしょと日本に生まれただけで世界中どこでも挑戦できるチャンスがある
その事実がすごい羨ましいそう言われたんです
ご存知の方もいるかもしれないですが
日本は世界で一番パスポートが恵まれているくんです
リザがなくても世界中190カ国に行くことができます
私は彼女たちにこの事実を気づかせてくれた事により
自分自身が日本人である事ってこれまで当たり前だと思って生きてきたけれども
当たり前じゃないのかもしれない
そう思った瞬間に
今見てる世の中も当たり前だと思っていることって
たまたま生まれただけでもしかしたら何も当たり前の事なんて存在しないのかもしれ
ない
そう思うようになりました
そして昨年帰国して当たり前のことは存在しない
その上で社会を見渡してみると
つまらないプライドだったりとか誰が決めたかもわからないような固定概念に縛られて
一歩踏み出したいと思っているのに一歩踏み出せない行動が制限されている人が多い
それを見たときにすごいもったいないなと思ったんです
ただなんとなく私も高校行って大学行って就職をしようと思ってたけど一歩踏み出して
出会う人と身を置く環境を変えたことによって社会を違った視点で捉えることができて
何かしなきゃ
行動を起こすまでに至ったのであればより多くの人が気軽に出会う人富岡
環境っていうのを変えることによって固定概念がとり外れて
一歩を踏み出せる人が増えるんじゃないかなその表現方法を模索していたときに
いろいろな人に出会っていろんな方の支援もあり会社を立ち上げるにあたりました
これが会社のロゴなんですけれども
でリトルという社名なんですねてリトルの意味には色々な人のテリトリーをシェアして
いくとっていくことによって自分自身のテリトリ固定概念がとり剥がされる
こういった意味が込められています
そこで事業として一番最初に私たちが環境を変えるっていう文脈で選んだのが中という
分野です
なぜかそれは
住居って普段の私たちを支える上ですごい大切な役割を果たしているはずなのに
曾我部に変えることができないんですよねこれっておかしくないかな
と思うようになりました
なので
住居っていう中という分野において出会う人と身を置く環境っていうのを気軽に買える
ことができるようなサービスができないからそれを模索する中で生まれたのが一番
ボートに見るたーーーーえっと weeks っていうサービスですね
vics は自分の興味趣味がマッチングする人たちと1週間限定のルームシェア体験
ができるサービスです
ただ
私も共同創業の前らもこの weeks を使って毎週
ルームシェアをして暮らしていたんですね
その中で半年間くらい家をなくしてずっとやっていたんですけれども
見えてきたことがありました
それは
の人が求めているのは
こういった住環境を変えるような理由ではなくて一樽に住環境を変えることができる
間違えちっ
仕組み作りだったんですね
リックスは1週間だけ違う人と暮らすことができるよっていうあるし新しい旅行
つまり移動する理由だったんですよではなくって私たちがサービスを通して学んだこと
は人が求めているのは移動する理由ではなくてそれよりももっとば前段階で気軽に移動
することができる環境を変えたいっ
思った時に一樽に誰もが変えることができる
そのハードルを下げることその仕組みづくりそれが大事だなということに気がつきまし
た
じゃあ派として人々が自由に気分に合わせて住環境を変えることができるようになった
世界
そこで人はどのような住環境に気軽にアクセスすることができたら幸せなのかな
という問いが生まれました
この動画をちょっと見てくださいね
じゃないん
がん
元こぼしてエラーで打っやで宮
これなの動画か分かった方いいます
ただの海岸のを撮影した動画です
これ昨年末に私が一人で中国の申請に行ったんですけれども
実です併設の
とに何も特別な事も無いただの海辺のを撮影した動画なんですよ
今の日本に平日の上を見にこれだけの人が集まる事って
ありますかねなかなかないと思うんですよね
でも
これらの症状を診てもらおう4日間
入ってるから
ランボルギーニはパンダにともせんだろう私たちの方を
ok ですよなので聞いてみたんです
ここの海岸に一緒に連れてってくれた中国の友達に聞いてみたんです
一番左のえっと写真左に写っている彼になぜこんなみんな楽しそうなのと海見てなにが
楽しいのと
聞いたんですね
そしたら
中国はこれからもっと良くなると僕たちは自分たちで未来を作り出しているっていう
そういった希望があるんだ
だから楽しいんだよそう言ったんです
なるほどと思いました
皮膚温を持つことで人は行動することができるのかと
さっきの通りに戻ってみます
果たして私たちが自由に住環境を変えることができるようになった世界でどういう住
環境に気軽にアクセスすることができたら幸せなのか
私の答えはこうです
明日も頑張ろうそういうふうにセンプルに明日に希望を持てるような暮らしに誰もが
気軽にアクセスすることができたらそれってすごいいいことなんじゃないかな
そう考えました
a ちょっとこれは今日はサービスの説明をハブってんですけれども近日中に
可能性とクラスをキーボのサービスを発表予定でいます
そこで気になったので希望の定義を調べてみました
東京大学に希望額っていう学問があるんですけれども
その希望学の教授が希望を雇用
このように定義しています
希望とは行動によって何かを実現させようとする気持ち
おそらくここにいる大半の人が規模って
第三者だったり社会から勝手に与えられるものだと思っていた人が多いんじゃない
でしょうか
私はこの定義を見たときに
なるほどと希望は与えられるものではなくて自らつくっていくことができる
希望を作り出すためにここでもやっぱり行動することが大事なんだ
それを再認識しましたん
これまでの私を振り返ってみると
ニューヨークに行って起業してサービス作ってサービス閉じてまたそこから学んで
新しいサービスを作ろうとしていて
すべて行動でつながっているんですね
そしてもっと考えてみると
今私たちがいるこの現実もそして未来もすべては私たち一人ひとりの行動が作り出して
いるんです
よく
どんなや未来をつくりたいですかとかすごい聞かれるんですけど
そんなの知るかって思うんですよ
うん
なんか日本は社会課題をいっぱい抱えてるだとか
帰還してそういう人も多いですけどだからこそ私たちが今何ができるかなというふうに
考えて一人一人が現実をしっかり捉えて行動していく
で行動し続けた先にしかその私たちが求めている答えていうのはないんじゃないかな
そう思っています
まだ何も成し遂げていないようなこんな若造が何を言ってるんだって私も思ってますで
も
だからこそ
わくわくするような未来を私は作っていきたいと思うし
仲間と一緒に行動し続けたいと思っています
行動した先にしか答えがないと思っているからです
最後に行動は言葉よりも雄弁に語るありがとうございました
[拍手]